hey let's go Ambrose this is you are
doing me the great honor of joining
today
[Music]
famous
you're so many do this is creepy what is
this it's not a pug so Kauai
doesn't sound like a mom voice oh hell
that's not good
now me hey Matt Matt alright don't give
her a cat don't
hasta stocking I got Ghosn the muita you
know me doggone you don't know I feel
like jump-scare coming and I don't like
it
[Music]
Oh
snip what about the kitty
[Music]
hey hey poor papers how could you
ooh
snappy oh my god it's a Seiko oh it is
Seiko
oh my god hmm and we are back in the
world of capes potty
this time book of shadows what an intro
so for those of you brothers who don't
know that was Naomi one of the main
characters from the first game who I
guess survived without her friend who
died in the world of course body
psychoshy in my story she lived though
but there's different endings and I'm
guessing that they're gonna keep going
as if she died and anyone who died in
that world no one else remembers when
they come back or whatever so there they
are sick Saeko is the one that buttered
the poop aright
or was it the opposite nice we got some
cow a [ __ ] going on ahead of us we got
some Sugoi [ __ ] butter pooping
oh my god anyway but the first game was
really awesome it is a total mind [ __ ]
what what is that like I don't even know
I hear this one is even more [ __ ] up
in the perverted ways and cuz I talked
to minks and she played it and she told
me there might be some parts where I had
to censor so yeah we'll see we'll see
how it goes I'm always excited to be
sharing these adventures with you bros
and this looks like a little that'll be
a great one so why don't you pop some
popcorn snuggle up in your cupboards and
tickle your nips don't do that place
that's weird
I mean you can do whatever you want but
actually not whatever you want but but
anyway perk up shadows here we go
alright so here we are at caps Betty
Becca shatters I can either play this
with or without their voice I can name
the game I thought I really liked the
voice acting in the first game it was
really really good
but at the same time it might be kind of
weird to just listen to that all the
time so I don't know let me browse know
what do you think but for now let's
start a new chapter the first one seal
and not the cute one
probably dammit ah what lovely weather
I wonder how are you miss faring at
school today
what [ __ ] who speaks like that I hope
she's enjoying yourself
who's he no a anyway the spirit seems
unusually active again though and
there's that old sense of unease - the
same one I you mean I have been feeling
all our lives but stronger than ever I
don't like it
Network bit are you me I remember I
think I can sense its presence it's
gotten very very close but that's
preposterous right I'm probably just
imagining things maybe it would be best
if I talked with her about it I only
hope nothing bad happens oh it will
Oh Wade Wilson no wait oh and Book of
Shadows episode 1 seal flop see it's
much better when I do it the voice
acting cuz they should get that [ __ ] I
threw down my bag collapse into the bed
and stared up at the ceiling so this is
not Oh me please where am I
these were my familiars the familiar
lighting no I can't I'm sorry the
familiar patterns I knew so well in that
familiar stain in the corner that my
uncle pooped on I remember when my dad
made that stain Oh your dad pooped ok
it was my 15th birthday
if my fifth birthday Jesus yeah they're
so young in this game it's so weird and
he just opened a can of soda had been
shaking why were you shaking a solar
signing up my ceiling was something I've
done million times before probably not
because you're like five but today it
felt strange like I just come from doing
the exact same thing hmm how curious the
hell is that puppet doing now is
creeping me out the green one with the
[ __ ] and I'm not talking about the
general act of lying in bed and looking
up but a more specific sense that I'd
experienced a singular moment and when
once in time once before others are you
me she looks identical she was in the
first game I believe the time you were
looking for its day Chevy supposedly did
Chevy signifies that a new destiny has
just been born within you I heard a
Chevy just means that you weren't really
paying attention or that
so congratulations Nakashima you may be
a whole new person there see much better
when I do it so said the class rep
making lights of this situation in her
usual creepy way oh yeah she's into
creepy [ __ ] but maybe she was right had
been more cognizant of my actions since
then who talks like that usually if I
pay too much attention to every little
thing I do I begin obsession
representing and then I just gave myself
a headache and end up calling it a quits
but this dish if it was real and it was
far stronger than he had any right to be
with the [ __ ] this wasn't your
run-of-the-mill spooky feeling it was
all-encompassing
[Music]
Sacco no matter where you where you go
in this house it all smells just like
you know me what the [ __ ] is this heaven
I swear Seiko doesn't need to feel like
this has all happened once before what
the [ __ ] is going on
what has you sleeping over there here
and then the next day we both like hey
let's go clothes shopping don't you
remember what the ah surely you just
I miss Seco so much long have I thought
sought to capture the and infiltrate the
walls of this holy temple but today
marks the first successful conquest hmm
yes I guess that isn't the sort of thing
I have forget quite so easily must just
be my imagination so kawaai finally our
flag has been planted say Konomi
together less you bet this is gonna be
lots of fun
what's all this about a flag oh I think
you know hey hey hey her boobs are giant
I'm sorry okay and so began my
first-ever slumber party with sickle the
moment 5th period ended that day we tore
right up school and loaded up on all the
junk food drinks we could carry drinks
white okay second I had been friends
forever but neither of us had stayed at
at each others house before so we were
pretty excited this is gonna be bye
Oh Naomi did you mind if I make a quick
call home the kids know where I'll be
but I should still check in says I
didn't have a chance to swing by sorry I
still have a call sure go ahead do you
need to use the landline no no my
cellphone should be just fine I'll just
worry about with a little poor you you
know oh yeah you he'd be sad if I didn't
at least call no wait who the [ __ ] is
you no problem you do your thing and
I'll take a quick bathroom break
hey I excited my room glancing behind me
to see psycho holding her cell phone to
her head with one hand while flashing me
a peace sign with the other well I like
the room-door thing pug thing the mere
idea that there'd be a friend waiting
for me in my room when I got back was
just so exciting don't you just feel the
same way brosé listen it's so exciting
oh the things we could talk about that
night wait should we start
what stewardess should we tell oh yeah
okay looks like dad's gonna be late
coming home tomorrow you so I'll head
your way after the festival's clean up
and and all the good pies then make it
again ready for dads special surprise
together okay yep give all my love to
the others and make sure you all tuck in
tight so tonight so you don't catch
colds take care of you
hey they holding up okay sure are which
means I got nothing to worry about I can
enjoy my time with you at the fullest
sounds like you're ready to have some
fun the hell are they gonna do together
exactly I'll bet you are too what the
[ __ ] where is this going
now me and Seiko so what should we talk
about
anything you'd like I'm just so glad to
have this blissful opportunity what it
what this is so weird
hey I really can't say why I felt so shy
and embarrassed because we shipped them
so much that's why the two of us are all
this together after all changing the
setting from school to my personal space
just seemed to bring us a lot closer I
find myself staring at seika's boobs I
mean face as if studying it
did she really always look like that
this is someone who they okay they're
there they're really into each other
this is this is not just friendship they
really go in full fanservice on this one
what the [ __ ] oh I just spent like a
frickin fountain that's up this game
he's doing weird [ __ ] to me bro
sorry I'll keep going this was someone
who regarded me as a friend all kinds of
inane thoughts were swinging through my
head and for some reason they were
making me really nervous and tickly down
there hey you know what we've got we got
that chocolate soda chocolate soda oh
Japan what the [ __ ]
want to try it out yes I would like to
do I just try and stop me
I took out the bottle of weed the
perches imported sophistic contents is
it two cups it had the faintest tinge of
chocolate color but was otherwise clear
as it hit the button of each cup that
familiar comfortable sizzle of a car
burning acid rising from the liquid
echoed forth emits a froth of bubbles
who translated this who writes stuff
like that well it's sure it's a pretty
color but what do we do with the rest of
it if it sucks reported operators we
take it with us to school tomorrow
enough for up to everyone because if it
sucks everyone else needs to taste it
obviously make room we're being real
nice see hey that's a great idea
all right here you go Seiko Thanks okay
let's drink it down on the count of
three sounds good one two three look
damn that's good before I knew it they
were up to our old tricks talking on and
on like with all the state at school we
smiled and laughed and felt joy at the
same things spending this time together
we could each forget all our troubles
for a while this was the kind of friend
that comes along only once in the left
hand I was starting to get really
sentimental and had no idea why I
certainly couldn't admit to her though
I'd never hear the end of it I just keep
thinking to myself I really hope Seco
and I could be friends like this clean
into adulthood for the rest of her life
even maybe it was same weird sense of
c'mere read Braille Beryl one tends to
feel during overnight field trips I
don't know
mister Nagashima this forest stupendous
come on now me say ah oh oh hey thank
you you two certainly are close aren't
you oh that's the mom assistant okay
hey I heard so much about you Shinohara
that I felt I simply had to meet you one
of these days ah now it's been talking
about me has she ah all the time during
meals you're always a hot topic around
here he never fails to have the same
story about where you two went or what
you did so I've been accepted by the
family then oh she's not the mom she's
like a maid or something my tears of joy
overflow at the prospect I must be red
as a beet right now beets aren't red
they're purple God thank oh oh it's not
just you now me also loves talking about
satoshi mushi that boy whenever he comes
up she just gets oh yeah excited I think
she likes
mom oh it is mom wait Mike what sorry
ixnay on the etosha nay say k said some
weird Japanese rap what the [ __ ] it
sorry D oh don't worry I know all about
your feelings towards her beloved
Machida no me may seem like a strong
girl but she's really quite the shy one
Seiko stop just stop
well you certainly well inform what you
say and I have a girls night out
sometime what do you say we have it okay
sorry I'll treat you to something good
and in return you tell me everything you
know about Naomi from school it would be
an honor and a privilege mrs. Nakajima
hey come on now
oh [ __ ] I'm so sorry I've drawn a bath
so you should head in while the waters
still warm I should I assume you'll be
okay going together since you're both
girls no this is so perverted this is
this game is so japanese damn straight
my flag is firmly planted now the day is
totally won huh what are you talking
about it are we really gonna bait
together and seriously what's all the
flag business about never mind that just
come on mrs. Nakashima we're going to
borrow your bathroom Roger that
make sure you two get nice and warm okay
say can I remove the labels from our
school uniforms on the way to the
bathroom dressing area I still felt a
little uncomfortable so I suggested we
bathe separately after all dammit
kidding I don't care but Seiko just
mumbled that resistance is futile and
set about taking my clothes out with
only a she did this is so weird
I'm basically reading a porno in front
of you bros allied portal what the [ __ ]
you brought you bros voted for this
alright
I'm adding tip are taking any up with
only a few swift moments she had my
whole outer uniform stripped away in no
time at all I thought I thought this is
supposed to be a horror game where she
was a bona fide pro a real expert I
talked taking people's clothes up
disturbingly well-practiced okay ah hot
hot hot
Tobuscus what are you doing off no
kidding the hot water at your house
doesn't mess around
yeah ma'am likes to brand world's
hottest baths I keep telling her that
when you're soaking lower temperatures
better but she never listens
oh well add two what's this is your body
feeling chilled well then take this she
slide her dick inside her what what
happened you're going to catch a cold if
you're not careful you've got to be
quick you're taking off your clothes
Sammy come on don't be shy here look
this is so weird
this is so [ __ ] weird Seiko had such
a dumb self-satisfied expression on her
face as she scooped up water in the
basin and dumped it all over our heads I
think your own shy enough for the both
of us I mean we're the one who tore off
all my clothes like they were paper mmm
well I do bathe my little brother's
every day so I've gotten pretty good at
speed stripping other people okay oh
okay that makes sense actually no it
does no it doesn't it really doesn't
make sense anyway you need to loosen up
here let's take this opportunity to
deepen our friendship all right yes yes
you've thoroughly broken me out of my
shell now how about I wash your back
have a seat oh yes plus
[Music]
all right
what happened to corpse wali what did
they do to cold spotty okay first things
first
they're supposed to be like twelve I'm
not sure about their age but I'm pretty
sure they're supposed to be 12 but
they're painted like their bodies are
like I don't know at least 18 so it's
just it's so perverted and the other
thing is like you know what let's just
get it okay I'll add it up a brand new
select all with body soap and began
washing seika's bath marveling at her
per perfect complexion okay I never
noticed before just what a classic
beauty she was okay
I bought this special just for you so I
hope you're enjoying it how does it feel
[Music]
mm-hmm yeah that's it right there
starting to question whether this was a
good idea of a playthrough or not and
that's when all language broke down and
the sound emanating from the bathroom
began resembling strange animus
animalistic cries rather than human
speech
[Music]
I'm reading a porno ah oh ah oh god you
sound demented
what do you mean ah mmm just a little
further up please
here uh yeah I'd yeah ah am i doing a
good job reading a porno I made you
itchy I bet all right hold still I
didn't take long for sickos back to
become completely involved in soap suds
but I could still detect a reaction to
my every touch
I don't know how to react to this
anymore this is so [ __ ] weird hmm
they did not act like this in the first
game they didn't know I'd act like this
hmm
don't tell me you're ticklish hey guess
the secret's out I'm really really
ticklish sure [ __ ] sure well in that
case it's a thorough washing dude she'll
get ya you're on the offensive today are
you wait stop cap yeah yeah sorry oh is
that I could hear you over the sound of
my furious fingerboard it'll get it when
you're older I was on for sure and
nothing was going to stop me from giving
sega's back the full treatment and next
up her vagina after all homeroom today
was spent sitting up the culture
festival so we both got pretty dusty and
a nice scrubbing is exactly what we both
needed haha stop squirming hold the self
oh man Saeko you're really slender your
shoulder blades are incredible like a
cat's are they I can't really see them
so I wouldn't know but for you it's all
about that sexy sexy collarbone watch
you sound like an old fogey or something
but so beautiful and so big I don't
think that's my collarbone you're
staring at
does she have a dick is that it's a tit
just staring at her dick isn't it as I
glaze that sicko staring at my chest
with hungry eyes I suddenly had another
flash of deja vu
an uncomfortable one my eyes differ -
Wernick there was some sort of mark
there a bruise that wrapped all the way
around Seiko what happened to your neck
did you scratch yourself or something
hmm something there it's pretty faint
but there's a red mark hmm don't
remember injuring myself or anything the
prisoner neck though a slight look less
spotty than you'd expected for made by
human hands it seemed more even like a
came from cloth probably result of
wearing her kimono cord tied around her
neck all day from the red bean soup
stand what a shame to see her pure white
skin so damaged I hope it heals soon
whatever it is no no no no I mean he
mm-hmm I can't hold back any longer
what now all right you know that's
[Music]
what happened this what happened the
course party if you if for those of you
who didn't see the first game it wasn't
like this all right this is not at all
what all right you know I [ __ ] it I'm
tired of questioning it I'm just yeah
I've just gotta grab that ass yeah chase
on I say go seriously cold down girl I
think you've gone totally mental on me
no she just wants to grab that ass I
just can't help myself you know we do
have a spare futon mm-hmm
don't worry I'm fine right where I am
two people sharing a single bed would
make for a warm night but either of us
rolled over the other was going to wind
up clean on the floor I offered the bed
to her and I was practically willing to
spend the night on a roll out futon but
she wouldn't have it well as long as you
don't feel too crowded I guess this is
fine as long as you don't freaking it's
old warm and cozy I love it if only I
could kiss you like this I'd die a happy
woman all right well that's nothing
wrong and it's nothing wrong with it
I appreciate it this is weird how the
game changed you know with that she
plotted her lips into shape resembling
the number three and looked at me
expectantly what had gotten into her no
we better not happy woman or no I'd hate
to see you die what damn foisted giggle
mm-hmm I was just thinking this is
really fun hey it was around that point
when I started to realize the truth
about psycho really it took you that
long huh took you that long after all if
an outsider were to witness her blatant
act of harassment that's what it is and
my complete dismissal of it they'd
assumed we were more than friends too
but it's not like I was actually in love
with her I really didn't feel that way
at all I just thought of her as a very
dear friend and figured the closeness
was we had was pretty normal
it seemed more natural in fact that our
behavior would get stopped that would
lead to a third party misunderstanding
every now and again and I just have to
set the record straight but honestly
even with situations like that arose
they were pretty fun in their own
strange silly sort of way you know it's
the first time I ever had a friend over
hey this is my first sleepover too sure
beats lying in bed alone I'd tell you
what hey hey Oh what you okay it might
have slap you a little too hard back
there you sure did put your back into it
slugger
but don't you worry I'm just fine Sega
was rubbing her face lightly where I
struck her but smiling from cheek to
cheek sorry again hey how about I come
over at your place next time we do what
do you say oh I'd say yes yes that way I
can introduce you to the little ones
you are absolutely welcome anytime
Thanks the moonlight crept its way
through my bedroom window dimming the
whole room at dreamlike low soon enough
I was beginning to nod off why was I was
I dreaming
no it was just my room I could feel
sakers warmth next to me is this a game
by the way oh really
I forgot that I haven't been playing for
a single second or maybe I was somewhere
else entirely in this whole world all of
my life experiences were just one big
dream man it's hard to form a coherent
thought when you're dead tired
okay well ah
well tomorrow's a big day let's get some
sleep you said it from a sleepover right
into a culture festival we're true
challengers hey don't you dare oversleep
if you do I'm pulling back the blankets
and putting an ice pack on your stomach
what the [ __ ] oh don't worry about that
I'm such an early riser I put
middle-aged women to shame I'll hold you
to that anyway good night sec oh please
don't touch my ass good night wow that
was quick
shaking my civics been exhausting I
could hear a calm telltale grunts and
rethink rhythmic breathing signifying
that she was out of cold she was out
cold but and I was contained and it was
contained Jesus Christ I couldn't get
over just how much warmth her body was
generating the previous night was so
cold but this was perfect she was like a
hot water bottle mmm so uh you're awake
I can hear your voice even from the deep
asleep Naomi you've experienced that
before during class remember if that's
some kind of ESP or something and wait
were you sleeping during class that's
not good
hey I have a question mm-hmm can I touch
your ass in the future even after you
get married will you still spend time
with me like this what of course I will
talk about a bolt from the blue for true
for sure so my snare so for true I mean
we're friends you know through thick and
thin and will always be hey thanks man
you're really a spaz sometimes you know
that take a wanked I mean yank the
covers up in overhead like some girly
enemy heroine the [ __ ] if she really did
think of me as more than a friend how
was I supposed to react now Naomi
mm-hmm let's always be together hey you
bet good night Seika good night
Saeko and i seem to be thinking the same
thing we were both so happy but there
was another side to the coin there was a
certain awkwardness as well it was a
strange sensation soon enough Seiko
began moaning and breathing heavily for
real she had fallen fast asleep facing
me curl into a fetal position as I lay
there staring at her head my hand moved
of its own volition and began gently
stroking her hair especially him it
didn't feel awkward or embarrassing at
all perhaps because I knew she was
asleep it just felt natural I slid my
hands more towards her back and
continued rubbing her head gently like a
mother would her child what the [ __ ] is
happening mmm what a lovely shape her
head has what the [ __ ] is happening
perfectly round I just kept stroking her
hair thinking about this and that
suddenly she clung to me and purred her
face in my chest
okay well she's still half awake yeah
what a strong scene this was but just
for tonight I was willing to let it
slide there there good girl good music
it's supposed to rain all evening so
make sure you both take an umbrella with
you got it ah thanks for the loaner have
fun today and Shinohara you'd be sure to
think about where you go on that date of
yours alright
yes mam she's not your mom you know
Seiko i woken up ungodly early and
pulled my futon away forcing me up with
a chill and a sneeze we both calmed our
hair and put our on our school uniforms
then scarf down breakfast the breakfast
my mom had made and flew out of the
house if we didn't hurry we'd be late
for setting up do I actually get the
plane out no no I don't all right well
we needs to play games anyway am i right
uh-huh things are looking pretty grand
this year - yeah it's really coming
together
and but I forgot I have to get
go get the bowls from the prep room Seco
you go ahead into class will you Roger
that
oh and I'll take your bag for you give
it here Thanks
it was a day of the culture festival or
casiraghi fest our school has a whole
lot of history to it and this festival
had been part of it for ages every
student in a junior and senior high
alike was busy getting ready for the
festivities which were due to starting
around 30 minutes I want to find out any
extra time afterwards to check out the
other class project with previously
washed bowls we were planning to use and
lay them out in the home ec prep room
with these poles in hand I proceeded
towards class 2 9 I climbed the usual
staircase and headed towards the usual
room stepping carefully so I wouldn't
drop any dishes the plane the plan this
year was to host a red bean soup
restaurant I could smell the sweet red
bean paste more and more clearly with
every step I took I didn't so much food
at breakfast and here we had even more
food rearing its head but when it comes
to sweets
I'd say bring it on bring it on sweets
I'm talking now traditional sweets
morning everyone these look like what
happened to covert boy they'll be enough
balls for today don't you think my you
oh yeah my you she looks older what the
[ __ ] good morning yes that looks like it
would be planting hey they are
Yoshiki a morning carcinoma morning
Satoshi either Satoshi I now me Satoshi
seemed a bit cut out of sorts
he just started staring blankly was he
still half asleep it parted me to see
him like that but I literally had my
hands full so I really couldn't dwell on
it I pushed on into the classroom so
this is the girl at the boy that Naomi's
in love with it's really I like him but
I couldn't actually see why what's going
on in front of my feet and I have to
admit it was kind of scary it would be a
real challenge not to drop anything
mm-hmm now meaning good morning my dear
yeah Seiko stop grabbing my ass
Oh Seiko haven't we already said our
good mornings anyway oh ho but can I
resist an opportunity like this
Naomi hands restricted unable to fend
off my advances look what you did you
what an [ __ ] giggle oh now that's no
good our table has to be kept clean
guess we'll have to go wash it all again
here I'll help
thanks sorry for the trouble what is
happening and so began the culture
festival all day we wore the clothes to
zoom he prepared for us and serve red
bean soup to our schoolmates that sounds
good I love red bean soup she made a lot
of costs to being experienced having
worked on the side of things in the
drama club for quite some time she even
did the suing herself putting all the
practice to the test and the kimonos she
prepared for us really were all are of
exceptional quality so good in fact that
they became a centerpiece for us
bringing in students from junior and
senior divisions alike they made for a
busy day maybe weren't tending to
customers we were chasing after the
slacker cash Enuma are or taking time to
check out some of the other class
project in the end not one did we have
real not only did we have really fun day
we also wind up being the most popular
classroom in the whole festival
all-in-all a rousing arousing sex sucks
[ __ ] it finally the clock struck 6:00
a.m. as our busy day drew to a close we
all stood around talking we kept saying
we should clean up but that kind of
didn't happen before I knew it there was
only seven of us left in the room
Satoshi class rep Seiko Mori Seiki
Kashi Numa Zuzu moto and myself it
seemed everyone else had already gone
home our homeroom TM mr. Shido showed up
with Satoshi little sister in tow so
it's all the people from the fur that
was in their first course body pretty
much
but they were they were it we nine
became deaf de-facto cleanup room what
the [ __ ]
de facto yep that's all of them ah
finally done good work everyone
the place is looking like a real
classroom again there's dumbasses went
home without help oh wait the guy with
the glasses also the evil guy helping
our sure going to get it Pete the mad
man you married oh not much of class
trip if I can't even hold everyone
together long enough to clean up after
yourself
yeah you better hold that against
yourself though you did manage to keep
Koshi numa here surprisingly shut up
inside the guy with glasses maybe Sousou
macho I'd wanted to say it's been really
fun having you here at least last few
months I can't tell you how many times
your positive energy helped bolster my
spirits what the [ __ ] always remember
that you're loved and respect even
though you have that stupid haircut we
may not have said much to that effect
but we've all been watching you blossom
here
I lent a hand where I could and did my
best to help guide you but ultimately
you walk your own path and become a fine
young woman
what the [ __ ] who says that as a teacher
me a theory it takes a special person to
achieve what you've done with you
without even realizing it it's been an
honor to serve as your homeroom TA so in
the first game she was about to quit
school not quit school but for another
she was moving so maybe that's what's
happening right now as well I wish you
all the best on your new school aha so
it is the same it's kind of like the
same thing as happening in a different
universe and a parallel universe maybe
t-thank yeah
unfortunately this Tara farewell brought
us all back to reality during the
holidays follow me it's like the first
game identical except with some softcore
porn to to knock it all off during the
holidays followed the culture festival
so sumo Joe was being transferred this
but this was to be her last day at
casiraghi Academy High School everyone
here loved her so this was a sad
occasion indeed even though she had that
stupid haircut she was truly a kind
person possessing no ulterior motives or
harboring no ill-will towards anyone
the thought of her leaving was just
plain depressing but time waits for no
one
and sadly the time had come for her to
say our goodbyes sorry as well final
hurrah our occult obsessed class rep
asked us to perform some friendship
droga there it is that's it and get your
so cute
Sachiko ever after this is the charm
that got them in trouble in the first
there it is upon mention in it she
procured a paper doll from her bag it
looked a lot like those proxy dolls you
sometimes seen she know shrines designed
to absorb bad Kamra in somebody's place
visually this whole thing just seemed
like the setup for a curse scenes or
something it was kind of scary and I
wasn't the only one who thought so
that's because that's what it is so you
do the charm and if you do it wrong you
end up in this hellish place where
everyone just [ __ ] dies so we know
that's gonna happen hey this is well
this is a charm that I found on the
Internet if you do it right then all of
us will be together forever too bad you
won't or will end up or we'll always be
friends anyway that's the gist of it
interesting so how did he make where's
the guy with the glasses I miss him no
don't do this
thanks thanks Satoshi [ __ ] thanks
seriously don't do this it's dangerous
our lives are on the line Jesus
Satoshi I like the music it's coming
[Music]
there yes where did you get it okay he's
there hmm
don't think you're going a bit overboard
hmm look I'm not joking I'm dead serious
here Satoshi had always been easily
spooked and it's in true form he was
pleading for his life that would stop
what we were doing it didn't sound that
scary
don't worry machinae this is my usual
creepy fear I gotta say it's rare to see
you get all this worked up so he
remembers maybe what happened in the
first one in the end eight of us
proceeded with the ritual as planned
while Satoshi setting out in front with
tears in his eyes what the [ __ ] it kind
of felt bad I kind of felt bad for him
but this was for isuzu moto we all
wanted to give her the best possible
send-off so all we could really do was
silently wonder what had gotten into him
please I'm begging you stop this don't
go through with it why don't anyone
listen to me cuz you're a little [ __ ]
that's why he's really serious like as
serious as I ever seen him what is it
Satoshi what is it that has you so
worried it's a time loop this has
happened before
all of this I remember it and what's
coming next is worse than you could
possibly imagine
giggle sorry but I I'm through trying to
convince you just be a good boy and wait
for us to finish okay Jesus a time loop
if six things in a Chevy like me and
some new destiny being born inside of
him like the classroom it said before
come on
come to think of it this just feel a
little familiar this room this
atmosphere this charm I obediently dug
my nails into paper doll but all the
while I was frantically foraging through
my memories trying to figure out what I
was missing we're going to pull on it
until it rips apart into nine pieces and
the count on the count of three with the
pallid face Satoshi quickly rushed over
and grabbed the paper doll itself he was
joining us after all it's him damn it
he's crazy holy [ __ ] I would never
[ __ ] do that [ __ ] if I knew about it
everyone else smile at him as if to say
finally you've come to your senses but I
was just starting to get really bad
feeling about this
no no there's definitely something wrong
here ready one two oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] no as soon as I reached the
hallway I feel I fell to my knees with a
thud God look no no no no no what was
that a person was pitch black but I
swear it was shaped like a person the
school infirmary door hung open near me
and in my panic state I swear I seen a
black shadowy figure within it oh my god
no
giant boobs I mean what just happened
that tart Missy Anne she came towards me
and into my body from every orifice it
came in through my ears through my mouth
I felt an enormous lump in my throat
blocking the flow of air in my lungs and
mom toilet eating me and brink of chaos
is that I was almost killed it felt as
if a cold hand reaching my body and grab
hold of my life's energy turning all my
internal our organs organs inside out
and leaving me for dead
my stomach was kerning my bowels were on
fire and my legs were all twisted round
themselves can pressure alone to stop
the human body this much the odium
flavor of my own gastric juice is still
gnawing at the back of my throat it felt
like I was going to throw up again but I
held it in
I remember this this blaze these
circumstances I've been here before I
know I have after performing the psycho
ever after ritual there was a hellish
noise when a huge hole appeared in the
floor and then I was here in this school
there was no sign of Satoshi or mich
shishito or the class rep or anyone else
only seka was still near me collapsing
ahead of heap on the floor
oh god that's creepy sacred I explored
the decaying building as best as we
could but there was no way out not a
single window out of the door could be
moved or even broken justice our last
shreds of hope had begun to vanish we
suddenly heard Satoshi's little sister
Yuka cry out from somewhere just around
out of sight I strained my ankle pretty
badly and couldn't walk very well so say
come enough alone to find her while I
rush to set up in the infirmary
the exact same thing happened in the
first game oh Jesus Christ oh my god and
that's when the dark shadowy figure
showed up and began attacking this
happened oh god stop please my nipples
are hard enough already
pant pant it was scared so scared so
scared so very scared my teeth were
chattering and my lips were quivering as
if they had the mind of their own
why would she leave me alone like that I
told her I'd go with her to look for you
gasps oh why why did she leave me behind
what's a guy wanted to slow her down
what's that going to get her in her way
now II what happened are you okay
what oh my god are you all right I'm so
sorry just seeing seika's face quelled
by shivers whenever she's around I feel
so at ease and at that moment I just
wanted to cling on to her and cry my
eyes out I should have done it but
instead just leave me alone do you have
any idea how scared I was
she always reacted badly like this I'm
so I'm sorry no me come on let's try and
find a way out of here together what's
the point just forget about it leave it
alone we're never getting out of here
maybe it was the safety of psychos
presence that did it but all their fear
welling up within me suddenly turning to
anger I was like a spoiled child
nothing good come out could come out
lashing out like this Seiko you didn't
do anything wrong I knew that but I
couldn't stop myself from saying what I
said she was genuinely concerned about
me and I sworn to myself that I protect
her but my sense of reason
was fighting a losing battle you realize
we've gone missing right how do you
think my mother's gonna feel she's going
to be worried sick about me and there's
nothing I can do now help me please
don't say things like that
it's gonna be all right like hell it is
she's gonna keep searching for me until
the day I've finally come home and she
has work you know this whole situation
it's not right as long as I'm here I'm
not nothing but a nuisance to her I'm a
terrible daughter and we're just gonna
die here anyway so all that time she
spent looking for me is will be wasted
but this time my mind had been
completely overtaken I wasn't myself
anymore I was running at him I was
running on out of power
horrified by the words coming out of my
mouth no I know how this ends you're
wrong families aren't like that it won't
be an oceans it won't be a burden you're
not terrible I don't know exactly how to
say this but when there are loved ones
involved you'll do anything for them and
I was again jashub you everything was
falling into place I knew what was going
to happen I knew what fate had in store
if we continue down this road but I
guess I can see where you're coming from
your mother is a really kind person she
the last thing you want to do is worry
her that's why we need to make sure she
that she doesn't that that doesn't
happen right now me I need to get back
home I don't know how it is for you and
your family but normal people don't work
that way no it's happening sakers coming
to get hanged she's going to die that's
what happened to the first game she got
really pissy and Seiko got killed and it
was really sad oh Jesus Christ I had to
apologize no I don't want you of all
people to speak to me like that please
Naomi tell me that's not how you really
feel Seiko
oh my god decisions well obviously I
will apologize right well let me do a
save just in case wait I can't click
apologize oh I can't thank God if I
didn't say something to calm her sake of
would run off and I know she couldn't be
by herself right now so I pulled myself
together and tried apologizing to her
but the words sake oh I'm so awful what
the [ __ ] yeah yeah
the words wouldn't come as soon as I
tried to form them something caught
itself in my throat I find myself unable
to breathe and doubled over in a fit now
me are you okay we suisse back I'm sorry
Naomi if I'm bothering you I'll go I
hate to leave your side but if that's
what you want I won't argue no don't go
Seiko Seiko wait
Seiko ran off in Jammu distance her
figure growing smaller and darker until
they vanish altogether I know I made an
awful in irascible mistake yeah that
sense of dread I felt moments before had
come back full force I could sense
animal a vole and within me and outside
hand that made me lash out at Seiko
it felt like something was in my mouth I
had no idea what but there was
definitely something in there
I stuck my fingers in and tried to dig
it out yeah oh god that's the scar ah my
finger find something and pull that and
from it my throat came large lumps of
black hair ah God what that [ __ ] I just
kept pulling and pulling and couldn't
believe how much they were all guide the
string the strand stretch all the way
from my stomach through my esophagus and
into my hands and even Bend there was
still more to pull ah
the motion was a natural and was
creating a repulsive sickening sensation
along my tonsils I felt like I was going
to throw up again
[Music]
where the hell did all this hair come
from what's this all stuck in my throat
ah it was only a faint notion before now
I was certain I was remembering some
future event I didn't know why or how
but I was repeating time and I just am I
just not allowed to apologize I could
feel a dark will guiding me someone or
something wanted sacred to be killed in
this timeline as well but it wasn't
going to let but I wasn't gonna let it
happen not without a fight Jaya I have
to go after her
I have to apologize I can't leave her
alone like this I ran as quickly as I
could in the direction Seiko had gone
but then a fierce earthquake began
shaking the ground the building it was
so violent
I couldn't even stay standing I cried
too longer on waiting for it to pass
everything was moving and there was
sounds of objects cracking breaking all
around me glass shattering Felix eyes
are raining I put down upon me I was
scared for my life so scared so very
very afraid I was sorry I was gonna die
maybe a big chunk of ceiling would fall
on me but the floor would open up on my
feet and swallow me whole I kept
wondering how Wade was going to end
what's that going to be crushed how
badly would he hurt you how long would
he go before I finally died
my head was swimming with all kinds of
words case scenarios why my body just
remained motionless on the ground I
never felt so helpless before I didn't
even care anymore how to take any
release I could get just to make it stop
but there was no release with me all I
could do was curl up into a ball and
pray yeah
shivers shake I wonder how much time had
passed it could be an only a moment a
few minutes or even a few hours for all
I knew but it did finally end in the
dark corner notice were silent once more
yeah I gradually loosen my stepfather
and Carling from the floor blotches of
dusts and wood chips fell from my hair
some of the finer debris had gotten my
clothings and crunch around like a brief
movement it was not pleasant it was not
pleasant I brushed myself off best as I
could and slowly rose to my feet
slapping my skirt in vain to clear away
any excess dust under the particles in
air were like a white smoke billowing
through the pitch-black hallway it took
me a moment to get my bearings once I
finally did though I almost wish I
hadn't the sight before my eyes inly
washed away with little hope as I had
what the fkd had completely caved in
part of the floor it was no longer
possible to continue down this hall no
longer possible to trail Seco oh god
damn it if I had been coming from the
earthquake only a few feet ahead
I'd be dead for sure swallowed into
whatever hell it lay down there what's
going on I knelt down by the edge of the
hole and peered within it was too dark
to tell for sure but if what I thought I
saw was correct then the ceiling in this
school were unreasonably high to make
matters worse it seemed like the floor
directly below had falling out as well
oh that's not good I didn't dare
considering just how deep this pit might
go all I knew was I couldn't risk
falling into it
shivering into terror I putted myself
what do I do can I get around it I have
to hurry I definitely had to hurry if I
didn't say it would commit suicide but
there was a still time I was separate I
was determined not to let it happen no
matter what I was going to save her I
was going to change her horrible fate
search mode the [ __ ] is this
I actually gameplay actual gameplay who
would have thought I need to look for
something this is weird
alright we're back I've been out buying
groceries and I've been having lunch and
I put the groceries back in the fridge
and yeah a lot of stuff has happened
since I was gone in like a second how
crazy is that still can't seem to I
should have figured this out before I
started recording son of a [ __ ] alright
let's keep it real here alright so if I
were here what would I do
I really don't see anything that piques
my interest so apparently now I have the
they took away the RPG element which is
really weird so I opened the menu with
you and then I can what this is so weird
search mode well I guess it's more
creepy alright there's a large hole in
the floor too big to jump across getting
to the other side won't be possible well
[ __ ] me then let's go oh my god ah well
I all guess we'll go everywhere oh okay
so things happen while we go there that
ah oh nice there was a mess of blood and
entrails on the wall as if some one were
launched across the corridor at
tremendous speed oh god this happened in
the first game - sorry I'm just gonna
keep saying that all over the smell was
positively vile say
go ahead come men commented on it before
but it was really hitting me now every
breath I took was triggering with this
fly is really pissing me off it was all
I could do it was all I could do not to
vomit again no can we go away please oh
well I guess I'll search it
so anything searchable here and this is
seem worth it all right well let's go
there then the door to the science lab
is frozen its place as if it's just the
decoration of the wall it can't be
opened
hiiiiii mama mia pizzeria es una bella
la casa the door is frozen yes yes yes
well we shall go in this hole then this
is weird they really made this game
weird as I wanted her the darkened
corridors every hair of my body was
standing at attention a detention I had
goosebumps from head to toe it felt like
a fog of any sness was swirling around
me with each step I took and that fog
was growing thicker and thicker to such
extent that I began fearing that
darkness might swallow me whole and I
cease to exhaust I could feel my sanity
slipping away I didn't know how much
longer I could hold out and I was
starting to lose patience I just wanted
to get it over with
fear was like a slime covering my entire
being no matter how much I wiped
I was only squishing it around it
couldn't come off it was stuck there
what is she talking about gross I'm so
good for you ah
I walked around aimlessly calling out
stickers name by doing so I think I was
able to dull my senses and just barely
maintain my grip on reality Seiko where
are you please answer me I wasn't
thinking thing I wanna play I did it's
so creepy walking in the corridors up
ahead I swear I saw a light glinting off
something it looked for a moment like a
web of summe strings stretch all across
the hall ah
oh I slowly crept forward until I could
confirm that they were in fact strands
of wire
gently Irish out a finger and touch the
closest one Oh God yeah I pulled my hand
away looking down at it there was now a
very fine clean slice right on the tip
of my finger tiny red beans were
beginning to form those beads just kept
getting bigger and bigger as I watched
'mentally swelling into one another and
forming a single drop of blood
well let's oh hello that's this [ __ ]
great isn't it
and that drop quickly became too heavy
for its perch it began wedding its way
down my hand towards my wrists we get it
you're [ __ ] bleeding piano wires no
it's a little different I couldn't
believe and I cut so deeply just from a
faint touch had it been sharpened it's
really strong stung if I hadn't noticed
he's wired strongly across the hall and
just kept walking
I shudder to think of what might have
happened Oh God
death not from Elephant spirits but from
a mere booby trap hey hey babe who could
have done this there was definitely an a
planned malice behind it I could sense
an ill will in the air and began to
tremble as well where why would you ever
think that was someone watching me I
even at this very moment was someone
just waiting for me to fall into their
traps and die so they could gloat about
it I love gloating there's someone there
hey excuse me
it was like an unconscious shout I
couldn't control myself I was scared and
I read whatever did this was heartless I
couldn't just let it go let it go sorry
stop this place you're scaring me don't
do these awful things to people that's
what I say every day to people my baby
I'm negative emotions began swimming
through my head I suddenly realized I
was crying and I knew that this corridor
with its web of razor-sharp piano wire
was effectively impassable at least for
the moment I needed to find somebody to
cut through the wires or at least some
means of disabling the trap at any rate
I decided to go back
and search the rest of the schools for
answer all right well whatever you say
now me whatever you say you bros hanging
in there in terror sorry my accent goes
thicker by the minute this means we
don't have much left to live breaths
this means the world is about to end
can we go here though yeah we can okay
I'll take it
whew the door to classroom 3a is
frozen's place all right well I heard
that one before let's check this note
smudgy blood-red alluring like getting
close to the darkness is one a way to
learn the truth this whole place it's
close to darkness after oh well that's a
great note made me really yeah yeah yeah
shut up doesn't look like there's
anything else we can't go there what
about here hello fine an one out Dart Oh
guys hey this this earthquake really did
it oh we can't me enter all right ooh I
wonder the classrooms look like oh
they're just wonderful aren't they that
looks like something No hmm it's too
quiet here I don't like it oh god what
is that oh oh oh the following words
were scrawled on the blackboard your
friend is a traitor you're going to be
gift right I always loved him the little
music in this game they shouldn't have
been there it wasn't on the board when I
first got here was psycho somebody had
written it recently but why to create a
rift in our friendship I don't know if
it was a person or it goes to get this
but whoever it was it was a terrible
thing to do this was all really started
to
get to me sorry it's somebody in there
stop harassing me whoever you are I
can't take this anymore I just cape and
go to tumblr and tell about it I didn't
even know whom I was angry with but make
no mistake I was seething I was probably
really close to my breaking point I ran
out of the room never even passing to
wipe my ass wipe the tears from my eyes
well that was great I loved that room 10
out of 10 favorite room look how many
places there's left to explore Qi our
asses crossed
let's go to one by one baby make sure we
don't miss anything but missing
something it would be terrible in this
game I would just cry forever there's
nothing here it's [ __ ] great should
we go up or I think yellow means we
can't go there so I'm gonna go here it
is a lot creepier with this but at the
same time I you know the RPG maker
effect it's kind of gone I wonder why
they took that away
the original corpse party the original
original one was made in oh god it's
more piano wire there was yet another
piece of piano wire in this room
simulate razor sharp like the others but
only one I couldn't worry easily without
with some care I don't know about that
girl that could be a trap and you could
lose your head that reminds me I should
probably say that was the dorkiest last
I ever done I'm so sorry what is this
thing in the corner of the room set and
antiquated mechanical certain oh it's
one of those those lever things it
prominently featured two wheels with
spools of Trance cooling these words man
translucent wire coil around them and
projected out towards the ceiling in a
perfect tight line could this be the
cells of the
a deed sorry booby trap
pull the lever yeah that's a pretty big
lever that's what she said
see sorry I wonder a filly even move aim
no the machine was old and leverage
rusted so it wasn't going to give
without a fight I could rattle it a
little though so I figured I had a
chance rock Oh
something Bad's gonna happen oh yeah ah
it's gone the piano wire it's a it's a
gone it's a me Mario well you live and
you learn and you die and you die
pull the lever oh yeah what the [ __ ]
so it goes on and off sorry let's pull
it one more time maybe that gets rid of
the other thinks the other piano thing I
don't [ __ ] know alright let's get out
of here
I just feel like we should uh oh what's
that light what the [ __ ]
there weren't any lights on in the whole
school was bathed in darkness yet in
this lone room small circle of light
just kept blinking on and off it seemed
almost as if it would turn on whenever I
look at it and turn off whenever I
looked away or maybe that was just
imagination but it seemed possible that
someone could be trying to get my
attention is anybody in there no
response what do you think Naomi what do
you think I began to get more and more
creeped out with every passing second at
first I thought maybe somebody was
watching me but now I don't I was almost
certain of it oh great a dead body
great great breasts that's great as I
got closer to the source of light the
blinking stopped the light was not fully
on god I don't want to look at that god
dammit it is a lot more creepier this
game I gotta say what do you both think
listen to your teacher you're going to
die now
well that's this [ __ ] road okay god
what's in here there are three lines of
deep scratches oh my god that was like
last time - I keep saying that but it's
true I seemingly made just watch the old
ones already God made by fingernails
what could have have happened here
there's a bleached white skeleton
wonderful sprawled out here judging by
the height in uniform has to be it
remains of a male junior high school
student looking closely there's a faded
there's a faded school named a tag
attached to his bosom
shut up Edgar
do you still collect name tags in this
game a flashlight and son I should just
take it maybe it was just alone
batteries and that's why or maybe not
all right now we have a flashlight it
really did seem to be low on batteries
all right I'm not gonna waste it alright
game
oh god alright well I think we explored
everything here
let's try one see one see can't you see
got a pee on you girl
that's it Oh wonderful picture as soon
as I entered a room I had a bad feeling
about it I don't know why that's such a
beautiful picture the silence was almost
defeating defaming there wasn't a single
sound to behead this room in this room
alone felt very different and yeah
there's a dead body down there I can see
it hi Oh wonderful a child's crayon
drawing very vibrant and colorful I say
that at least the subject now is open oh
[ __ ] you don't say she seems to be
eating a Warren Malone where where's the
[ __ ] water Malone I don't see the
water Malone what is this there are two
skeleton remains here both of them
mostly where there at this point they
seem to have died and howl up against
one another well that's cute hashtags
cute hashtag just little things with
your boyfriend both our female Oh
hashtag little things with your female
friend look at round junior huh
there's a school name I don't care about
their names cuz I don't know what the
[ __ ] they are god oh I ate a student
today oh I was hungry so that well yeah
I mean plus we played
rock-paper-scissors and I lost I thought
I'd lose to an adult but didn't great
story my favorite story of all time just
love these stories that day alright
here's something
it's full of dirty tissues kind of turns
the stomach but best not to look any
closer best just to walk away what the
[ __ ]
Oh is she talk so listen alright well it
doesn't seem like there's anything else
here oh can we go there
let's try and go there oh stop somewhere
damn it
so we can't go there let's try and go
here then so the game will stop you at
least so you don't have to click through
it each one of them so creepy yeah
over by the stairs whew oh I don't know
likey to stare at those huh oh yeah yeah
how do I go out there oh god it's so
creepy let's go here love exploring
that's my favorite
weird we didn't run into anything what
is this place oh god this gives me goose
bumps this is actually legitimately
freaking me out of a oh god I'm so on
edge the door chill drivers the frozen
in place
oh that's it but there's a dead body
there Oh God
a decomposing corpse the smell of
ghastly judging by the height it was
probably alright well I'm [ __ ] now so
we can't go there either let's check if
the piano wire is gone because we pulled
the lever I feel like that's the
appropriate thing to do I gotta gotta
watch that [ __ ] go all the way here we
go
help me please somebody help me who said
that
who's saying that hello what Oh God
Oh No ah Nakashima grade three room a
Nakashima grade three room a please
return to class immediately what the
[ __ ]
hello hello
why can i this is weird me you're next
huh what the hell does that mean we read
this one right kidding yeah
[Music]
wait what what's that some sort of
mechanism pull the lever
yeah oh la la la hey what a strange
contraption pull the lever made a
retractable floorboard extend but it's
also restrung in all the piano way I had
to be careful not to touch any of it
even if it's slightly brushed up by a
single strand all right well now we can
go forward to 2f 3f hey is that saris I
think that's another start yep another
one what a sadistic place to put it it
should be possible to use the stairs but
that piano bestest okay don't fall got
it
damn this ambience man [ __ ] creepy as
hell I don't trust anything at this
point
nice right the stairs again creepy ass
[ __ ] stairs don't kill me Oh God not
the boys a girl bad things happen in the
boys room
bad things please don't be dead psycho
psycho psycho her name should be psycho
[Music]
let's board it up damn girl
alright well girls room it is huh I
don't like this I don't like this one
bit
hello
shaky fetid faded lettering could just
barely be made out on the old flyer put
it out of your mind
don't worry eat laugh go nuts led to dog
as in suddenly I felt a sickness in the
pit of my stomach it was almost time
bear
it's happening and be alive I felt like
I was forgetting something something
absolutely crucial something I could was
consciously trying to forget but
absolutely had to remember no matter
what to take a [ __ ] there it is to take
a giant dump up poop we do papa bouba
Papa that's a great name for it no
there's no there's no going inside like
last time what about the poppity Papa
Papa Papa Papa D probably paper - Papa
Papa Papa Papa Papa beat the Papa poop
sorry I'm so sorry they have those weird
toilet things there that's [ __ ] gross
well that was anticlimactic maybe it
will do like last time you exit and then
you hear something or you know not that
at all what the hell where are we
supposed to go now I can't go back
either this is
really strange the board should be
sturdy enough to get you across where
some sort of making it yeah okay so I
can leave okay
[ __ ] weird man so where are we
supposed to we never went to the nursery
this game is so creepy it's freakin
Japanese subtleties man what's in here
there's bound to be something here the
infirmary was where I'd been attacked I
didn't want to stay any longer then I
had to that horrible sensation of my
body being overcome by hair like mist
was something I'd never hope to
experience again as long as I lived
let's think my girlfriend is mm-hmm-hmm
there was a photo here who he looks
handsome the paper was cracked and
warped in various spots and the picture
itself was back and white clearly this
was not a recent photograph Thank You
Naomi for pointing that out
it was a simple shot of a man looking
directly at the camera doesn't really
look like he's watching out whatever and
a former okay
[ __ ] it I don't care I wonder who it is
was the man who worked at this desk or a
family made me maybe huh I think maybe
we have some other more important things
to worry about psycho all I mean no me
All Things Considered there's
surprisingly little dust on these beds
there's nothing either that may sir know
anything good there's a pair of scissors
ooh I could use that no sting why don't
you take the scissors and if I can cut
the shape
come on I don't care
not number of bottles each one of them's
banging what don't care give me
something so I can progress come on
[Music]
heater damn it damn it I'm stuck didn't
take me long it didn't son of a [ __ ]
what's stopping me here is it the floor
and it's [ __ ] nest floor you could
easily jump over though being centered
on [ __ ] imma let's try this we're gonna
go ahead we're gonna pull the lever and
we're not gonna cross how about that see
what that does all right by not cheating
whatsoever we're gonna we're gonna go
back here in the god shit's happening Oh
God yeah yeah I got it I'm that's
literally what I'm going you're wasting
my time here woman oh god oh god why me
yes yeah just shut up shut your damn you
literally just waste everyone's time
here okay maybe that's not what I wanted
to go at all also it shouts out every
time I pass it oh oh that is that is
some spooky [ __ ] man woman child deines
dinosaur really Oh weird you're weird
all right yeah you got a bad feeling
we're [ __ ] are you gonna do by now what
what
is she saying how I oh god it hurts
die just die I killed Oh God
oh my god I got goose nips like [ __ ]
crazy this is really creepy
hey girl so Donnie Robin it's like a
pomegranate take a closer look sure did
someone draw over it with fluorescent
paint gives me the creeps
oh my god the [ __ ] am I doing here then
can I go home now
oh my god
I don't see anything no I mean where why
would I click that was something maybe
there's another message on the note no
it's the same spill your blood I don't
know what you want me to do what if we
leave so creepy
Jesus let's go back oh my god this game
is so creepy are you bro scared we've
been playing for quite a while but we
have a lot of four oh god it's it's the
same [ __ ] yeah it is
I get it I can't go in there so you're
really making it hard for me here shut
up shut up shut up it just opened on its
own
Oh God come in Oh God Wow Oh God Oh God
come on in some unknown force lifted me
off my feet and pulled me in the
classroom it was dark in there that I
couldn't even see my hands in front of
my face Jesus I'm glad you've come ready
there's no time to lose Thanks I'm a
nation is about to begin please remove
your jacket ah ah that's a good girl now
lie down on the bed not sure what else
to do I pull out the flashlight and
pointed in the direction of the creepy
voice oh god oh god I have ten seconds
no oh god I'm running out of time here
don't kill me please
so Donovan helluva day vice-principal oh
great it's the crooked man oh hey
hey buddy don't worry about a what
suddenly the classroom was bathing that
familiar faint light and I was alone
despite what I've just heard and every
window seemed to be fully intact God
what's next what the hell was that that
was not fun not for how am I still alive
no one knows let's go back up to the
bathrooms
I don't know seems like the right thing
to do got to pull that lever though
sweet sweet lever
please let me across it's sweet I'm not
really doing anything to progress just
[ __ ] [ __ ] happens while I walk around
like an idiot great way to describe this
game right now I know it's like first no
gameplay now weirdest [ __ ] gameplay
ever so [ __ ] weird why did I go there
I want to go to the girls room come on
iwannapeepee
I want a pee pee on you but oh oh
no matter how much I wondered I just
couldn't seem to figure out where to say
greater enough to I'd been teased from
the shadows and frightened the whole
time I was searching I couldn't take
much more of it as losing my mind when I
came back to my senses I find myself
standing in a hallway no roads floor of
the school building I began to doubt
myself to doubt
the fated events that lay ahead or
whatever these horrific future memories
were I couldn't actually happen it
couldn't actually happen right I had no
real reason to doubt the things I've
been envisioning of course but I kept
telling myself it was just paranoia I'd
experienced déjà vu many times before in
my life ever since I was a little girl I
didn't have to mean anything someone
once told me that tissue it was just
brain recognized in a similar situation
from one's past and making a false
connection holding the wrong file yeah
exactly that's what it is Naomi don't
worry you'll be fine please please stop
our sake off Seiko please don't leave me
by myself I'd basically lost all the
ability to reason as if my mind had been
taken over by some outside force I broke
down on the spot and began crying hey
it's bucket
hey bucket are you doing what's that a
loud sound caught my attention it sound
like someone's kicking a wall I shot up
from the ground as if I were yanked and
as I rose my brain began recognizing a
similar situation from the power God my
file was being pulled
oh god no the sound of a struggle coming
from inside the bathroom stall is
exactly the same go now me oh god this
is gonna be bad isn't it
yeah god there's an eerie stillness in
the air within the weirdest laboratory
it didn't feel like there was anyone
else in there with me but I sense a
slight movement on the third stall from
the back as if whatever's Oh God
just go away my heart was racing I was
so nervous I felt like old blood in my
butt had begun flow in Reverse behind
this door
oh well at least she's not there
Seiko where are you I miss you
just looking at the news send a wave of
dark feelings through my mind the
specter of death was right in front of
me
baring its fangs if I went too much
longer without finding her ah that same
dull thud echoed again from behind me
stalled I turned back towards the soul
no one was there so what was i hearing
the world there's a breathe oh yeah
there's a hole behind this place I
stepped inside I began lightly knocking
on the back wall in several different
spot oh it's Hollow
looking closely the wall did just jut
out very slightly around that exact spot
unconsciously I pulled on him and a
small piece of paneling swung out into
the space beyond like a door it was well
hidden to say the least
never once would I have a guest there'd
be hidden room been this particular
bathroom stall it's really talking there
the room was extremely narrow making it
feel longer than it was
you could fit maybe two tatami mats on
the ground here and Jen what the [ __ ]
does that mean these Japanese
connections the hole was cut into the
floor in the back outfitted with a
ladder leading down into the main school
building below I peered down the hole
but couldn't see no sign of a floor nor
the end of the ladder this thing could
lead all the way to ground lever or even
further ah whether due to pressing
pressure differentials or breeze in the
air the secret door suddenly shut itself
made dammit I'm so [ __ ] that must have
been what I was hurt hearing earlier a
wretched smell was waffling up from
below hardly a surprise giving where I
was I didn't want to imagine what
unspeakable things might await me at the
bottom of this ladder but if say kibou
had gone this way I shook off my
misgivings and began to say
now we're going down I thought we going
up now that that that's the sound of me
putting on my rubber underwear shudder
forever shiver I wondered if maybe this
ladder ended in the garbage shell or
something I stopped in my tracks
seriously considering turning back but I
didn't want to miss something
and have to do this again later so I
figured I might as well go ahead ba ba
ba you kept climbing down sure it was
wikked if I'm not careful I might slob
oh god this is gonna be bad yeah over in
the cave I'm really glad it's not a
garbage dump it seems to be in a cave
like room with money moles and dirty
floor looking up I could see a very
faint light coming from the hole I just
climbed through but the whole area was
otherwise pitch-black here's the funky
music again Bruce do I look creepy I
[Music]
just look stupid a while thank you
there doesn't seem to be anything to
find in here at all I probably I'm proud
I'm probably just wasting my time while
surveying my surroundings as the best I
could I attempt to stand up but that
didn't go where
ah what they my ankle had swollen up
pretty badly oh yeah she hurt her leg
and felt like it was on fire it was the
same sprained ankle stager had tended
earlier I must have landed only when I
slipped from the ladder extravagance
crab-eating it further No
why is this happening because your [ __ ]
know me that's why I made another
attempt to go up there's time unto my
good ankle if I shifted my weight so the
majority of it rested on that like maybe
I could walk yeah shut up
no such luck I wasn't going anyway shut
up I was stuck in the dark dank in the
dark dank date when no one could ever
find me with a ladder I couldn't use my
leg has begun to going numb and the pain
from my ankle is almost unbearable you
know no I have to get out of here I have
to damn [ __ ] mouth you dirty [ __ ]
leaning on the wall for support I
attempted to stand much more
this time holding my sprained ankle in
the air as best as I could
I placed both of my hands on the ladder
but it was no use I couldn't even make
it the first step pant pant
what the [ __ ] where were we yes we're
dying great but as soon as the other
came in contact with a button rung of
that wet slippery ladder why can I hear
anything
Oh God I'm missing like out on actions
and stuff oh there we go
urgh off yes I could feel myself turning
pale I was well and truly stuck it was
no joke I was frantic
I tried climbing ladder again and again
but just kept finding myself sprawled
unceremoniously across the ground I
nailed that world word dammit look I
couldn't even say how many times I
challenged those damn rungs
I even starched a walls nearby for
another way out but it was simply no use
tears were welling up in my eyes
uncontrollably I'm so sorry
[Music]
and then all of a sudden I sense the
person in front of me Oh God if you want
to find your friend you can't just give
up I'm impressed you made it this far
you've done well oh it's all God it's
her she's evil don't trust it was a
little girl she was just there and she
spoke to me in a very comforting voice
then she hugged me tightly as I as if
trying to ensure out my head with her
being we saved her in the last game so
maybe now she's nice to us
sob sob broth there there it'll be all
right I'll let you see her if you'd like
really will you listen to what I have to
say oh I didn't care who I didn't care
if it was a person or it goes I just
wanted somebody anybody to save cycle
okay good girl good girl that's a good
girl everything's going to be okay
painful memories you see our the
funniest of them all sorry that's really
creepy no god ah now me you insensitive
jerk that was a weird psycho now hit
kicked sniffle no I shouldn't say that
about her it was my fault
Naomi was scared and after what we went
through I don't blame her she's always
been so cherry and so kind but I brought
out all her pain all her tears and
that's the one thing a friend should
never do a smile suits her best suits
our face best of all I'm sorry I'm so
sorry Naomi I'm sorry for making you sad
I feel so lost without you
it's the same for me psycho psycho I'm
sorry I'm so sorry please forgive me I
just I just wanted us to be together
forever help me but when I'm with you
don't I make you mad brah don't I rub
you the wrong way and make things
unbearable for you of course you don't
that was just me being stubborn and
pounding and behaving like a spoiled
bright Oh psycho approached me with her
arms outstretched she wanted to hug me
and I immediately obliged without slide
what is happening how is she walking is
a cycle warm inland life soft and
smelling lovely as usual the scent of
beeps new perfume I'll never let you go
again
let it go sorry sir me neither
you'd better not there's a
japanese-style room over there within
with tatami mats and everything we
should go sit down and try and calm our
nerves at all hmm
break sounds nice let's go let's go
sorry
custodians closet this is one of those
doors that wouldn't open isn't isn't it
oh I passed out earlier I guess wait so
we are actually together now I thought
she was just dreaming or something I'm
kind of confused still when I came to I
was lying down in this room I was
someplace underground I think with no
way out and then I saw a little girl was
it for the life of me I just couldn't
remember clearly okay hmm that's really
odd maybe you have a guardian angel on
your side or a ghost oh she ain't no God
in angel I tell you that much buddy come
on don't say that well remember what
that spirit told us when we first got
here
he said not all ghosts are bad not all
bad huh Saeko calmly opened the door and
stepped into the custodians closet I
could hardly believe this was the same
person who got scared out of her mind in
the first sight of a ghost only a few
hours before sorry you seem a lot more
fearless now than you are when we got
here psycho or is that just me mm-hmm
hey as long as you're around know me I
feel like I got nothing at all to be
scared of that's all well and good but
just make sure you don't let your guard
down okay we're [ __ ]
what is this room there weren't any
working lights in the custodian closet
but it definitely felt a lot safer in
here than it did out in the creepy creep
creaky hallways the two of us plopped
down next to one another on the tatami
for a long while neither of us said a
word I get I guess we weren't sure what
to talk about I'm so glad you're okay
cycle hey you two now me how's that
ankle still hurt I feel like it did
really badly for a while there but it's
totally fine at the moment hmm glad to
hear it
did you manage to find the paper doll
scrap
no it's still missing guess I've dropped
it somewhere else and finding anything
in this place is quite a feat yeah it is
I'm sorry but when we get it back we can
always ask the class rep to perform the
original again then we can get you a rip
then we can get you a replacement so
they know about all the stuff hmm that's
true
once we calm down a bit we reached a
point where we simply didn't want to
leave the room anymore
we had no desire to go back into those
halls so we didn't we stayed right here
where we were for a long time just
chanting aimlessly within one another
casual lists can be about class and the
festival and our sleepover the previous
night ordinary everyday conversation
well that's [ __ ] weird but then I
happened to look over and catch the sake
of staring at me yeah totally hmm Saeko
is something wrong huh oh no it's
nothing
mm-hmm it was too dark to see seika's
feature in any great detail but
something seemed to miss it was her face
was she blushing now me hmm this is hard
for me to say but well what is it I uh
she had an uncharacteristically serious
expression on her face and seemed really
nervous
what was it psycho what were you trying
to tell me I nevermind hey what the hell
I'll come on now my curiosity is killing
me just spit it out already
promise you won't laugh if you don't
want me to then I won't okay because I'm
totally serious
my heart skipped a beat this was the
beginning how could I have been so dense
all this time
since we have no idea what's going to
happen to us in here there's something I
really won't need to tell you okay
will you kiss me haha I want to kiss you
why because I love you as a friend right
Seiko didn't say a word she just shook
her head fervently I was dumbfounded
was she confessing to me I hadn't even
had a boy confess to me yet she hung her
head low staring down at her feet
my silence seemed almost like it was
causing her physical pain she looked
like she might explode I couldn't see
her face clearly but it was certain she
must have been quivering and blushing
from ear to ear
you're serious I'd marry you if I could
I want to kiss you and hug you too that
was the first time I ever heard psycho
speak so softly or with such a stammer
in her voice just kiss her already
before I knew it I was crying and I had
no idea why I psycho I'm sorry I really
she just run away I ran out of the room
and just took off down the hall I still
couldn't tell why I was crying it's like
I was scared or maybe I was happy or
maybe I just lost a friend
I needed to calm down the psycho I was
friends with wasn't gone she hasn't been
lost regardless of whether or not I was
able to return her feelings I owed her
at least a thank-you
ii was have been pretty deep in regret
by that point i needed to get back to
her i needed to let her know that i
would still stand my hair why don't you
just kiss her Jesus Christ woman oh my
god this is getting really juicy I was
suddenly distracted by the sound of
dripping water nearby It was as if
someone had left a faucet on but only
just
and it was slowly spilling out on the
floor but where was it it sounded close
yet there was no sign of running water
anywhere that I could see I had a bad
feeling about this all I knew was it was
close like really close wait no it
couldn't be
I looked down at my feet in that gasp
huh Oh God God what no black period
that's great and a pleasant looking
black fluid was running down my tights
and piling up on the floor beneath my
feet and it wasn't stopping goddamn it
yeah what the hell what is this I
hesitate aliy collected a bit of it on
my finger and studied it it wasn't blood
it was almost tar like inconsistently
smooth and vicious that's disgusting and
it seemed to be faintly glowing as well
why was something like this coming out
of my body
ah I went to wipe my finger on my skirt
and shift it in place only to lose more
footing and fall backwards landing on my
rear ah I put my hands on the side of my
head close my eyes and scream I'd
reached my limit
I just wanted all this to be over but
try as I might to shut out the world the
world was determined not to be ignored
it was like heaven and earth were moving
all around me
I felt dizzy it was like my soul and
blood buddy were separating
I became AK accurately aware of my own
mass and started obsessing over it I was
so heavy my head in particular the human
cranium weights about 5 kilograms and I
could feel every last gram straining my
next muscles it was hurting my back
what's happening I'm losing
consciousness I can't open my eyes
all the blood in my body came rushing
into my head why was this happening I
could feel the blood vessels in my face
pressing against my skin I could see
blood behind my eyelids oh god it hurts
it hurts so much
the blood just keep coming I couldn't
stop it felt as if my blood vessels my
eyes my whole head couldn't burst I
could burst at any moment Jesus somebody
police say me psycho be careful you're
about to fall into the valley of past
and future memories just as my last
vestige of consciousness we're fading I
had a little girls voice but I was in
pain I was weighed down I couldn't open
my eyes if you wish to save your friend
you'll need to overcome fate itself what
what are you saying
ah the heaviness of my head grew at an
alarming rate and I heard a tearing I
heard a tearing sound behind my ears it
was a sound of major blood vessels
breaking wide open I was certain I was
going to die but then the pain and
dizziness simply vanished what is
happening I had the sensation of faint
shimmering before my eyes and I wonder
if maybe I could open them now
slowly and carefully I relaxed the
muscles that were so forcibly and
fearfully holding my eyelids shut what
the [ __ ]
so we everything is so weird breast I am
so confused where I am I you know where
you are
this isn't heavenly host
I knew exactly where I was I'd seen this
image a million times before I'd seen it
just this morning with psycho it was my
house huh am I really home was it all a
dream maybe oh you'd be so lucky Naomi
you'd be so lucky I don't like this
where's psycho why did she have to run
away I get so tired of now I mean her
[ __ ] attitude mom I'm home something
wasn't right my field of vision was low
to the ground and everything around me
looked much larger than it should what
was going on now me guess what I brought
you a cat Oh dad you shouldn't always be
so mature watching the house all by
yourself when you're away come on pet it
it sinks she great now me uh mom naive
you got someone to keep you company
sorry we always been so late coming home
from work sweetie it's so nice that we
can trust you though I'm really sorry
but now you won't be lonely anymore
right
stop this me would spend half her time
indoors and the other half in the back
yard as if she were out to pasture or
something it may not have been much land
but that was her territory and she
rarely ventured outside of it once I was
so upset that my parents were going to
be late coming home from work again that
I scooped up me and ran away from home
for a little while papa mama
I hate you well damn stop it
it's because you're here May because
you're here Papa and Mama don't think
they have to come home it's your fault
you know
don't hurt the kitty now me what's wrong
why are you crying
where did you and Mae run up to I'm
sorry mate I don't want it to be like I
said a really mean thing to you me I'm
so sorry
now now it's all right now me Mae will
always be there for you she loves you
you know she can sense exactly how you
feel and she's very understanding
bow-bow sorry it wasn't long after that
that Mae ran away
typical cat-like behavior I searched for
her every day through teary eyes but in
the end she never did come home it's
such a pity I guess I mean cats get
strange ideas in their heads from time
to time that wasn't it and you two were
such good friends too I did this but
you'll make a new friend in no time you
just need to put this out of your mind
and move on it's because Mae was so
understanding and kind-hearted that she
disappeared from my life if only I
hadn't said that what I said to her ah
so we're going on the guilt trip here
about her [ __ ] cat that's just
[ __ ] amazing isn't it may come back
please mate uh-oh
you never change do you mom mom where
are you
she's not here now me that psycho
uh-oh psycho psycho hey are you all
right I've been looking all over for you
I'm so sorry about before she didn't
respond but she didn't have to this was
definitely psycho I can't see you very
well come a little closer please let me
see your face let me see your face but I
was please come a little closer here's I
drew in towards psycho who was sitting
on the ground and rested my head on his
shoulder then I wrapped my arms around
her I still couldn't see her face I
thought it might be because of the dim
light in the room but no that wasn't it
something was very wrong here psycho
wasn't moving an inch and that's when I
realized her skin was cold ah she's dead
wait where I was I was I at home or
what's this heavenly host the last thing
I remember was frantically trying to
find her again I could smell incense
from somewhere far off and finally
realized that this was in reality pant
pant pant pant pant kishi now arriving
at kissy-kissy station no no this person
sitting perfectly still on the floor not
saying a word that this is wasn't psycho
so who was it oh that that's nice glowy
eyes I guess that should be good in the
dark now me pant pant pant pant pant
when they within the unyielding dark
this is so creepy
within the unyielding darkness I knew
that whoever it was talkie whoever was
taken save psychos shape was coming
towards me
yeah she's hey she's riding next to me I
can feel her breath uh I can sense her
presence who are you
I'm your friend with a broken neck
remember oh god it's the one from before
this is the future where you make me die
no no why did you leave me by myself
back there after we finally managed to
get back together - I was so worried
that I'd hurt you so worried that's why
things turn out this way no don't say
that as I lay there stricken with grief
I heard the footsteps of a child
approached I look up and saw a little
girl with the red dress standing over me
I hate that [ __ ] [ __ ] do you do you
want to save your friend no matter what
it takes
who what are you I'm the one who
controls the fate of this world I had no
clue what she meant by that but I
remember that she'd been giving me
advice this whole time she had a
different air about her than the other
spirits around then the other spirit is
run in the school building I felt like
maybe she was on my side I want to save
her please there's some way to do it
tell me how I'll give you another chance
to remember sink hard what you've just
seen are events from your past which is
also the future though which your spirit
now passes over in the fourth dimension
in other words this isn't the first time
you've experienced this sequence of
events but you already knew that didn't
you
this sort of thing doesn't happen it
should have sounded like a complete
nonsense to me
sorry oh my god
thank you but I didn't say a word I just
nodded
they were only fragments but nonetheless
I was seeing crystal clear visions of
what I could only assume was my first
time experience these events the sense
of deja vu had been feeling be feeling
just some crazy dilution or missing dye
miss identified nerve impulse in my
brain it was real then you've also
already seen the trigger event from
which you've just your despair resonated
so now you fight against this is the
fate the demise a bucket a bucket how
you do make it that's great packet when
I came back to my senses I find myself
standing in the hole in the third floor
to the school building oh god no when
did I get here how long had I been here
I'll look down and sure enough there was
puddles of black all over it was that
vicious fluid that had been spilling
away from out from inside me I Paul Papa
Papa in manifestation of dread spreading
out across the floor but this was no
time to sulk I had to find about I had
to think about Seiko I left her all by
myself again I wonder if she was
stealing custodians room that sound it
was coming from the inside the bathroom
god damn it now this again there was a
violent banging coming from one of the
stalls with the lump in my throat and
shaver down my spine as slowly crept in
to take a look
oh boy there was an eerie stillness in
the air within the girls laboratory it
didn't feel like there was anyone else
in there with me but I sensed a slight
movement on the third stall door from
the back open it think about it
hey this was the source of all bad
feelings and uncomfortable premonitions
I'd been having I knew when I was going
to find
I remember this future now please simply
psycho this is the future I absolutely
had to prevent from coming to pass the
image of what waited for me in the stall
was burning my memory Oh God
God no no no no no and now it was now a
reality thank God now suckier still
alive
I'll save you oh god sorry once again a
flash of the side of future that I
waited us if I made it wrong move here
but there was still time I could still
save her hold on I'll get you down but
how her news is pretty high off of the
ground
it needed some way to get about on the
neck height in order to pull her down
safely something to stand on
bucket I guess I'd be right back psycho
I'm going to get somebody stand on
I heard out in the hallway to grab the
bucket I'd seen sitting in front of
their ground earlier if I were to stand
on that I was certain I could reach
psycho snacked even on my height come on
just [ __ ] grab it
there's rotten meat inside great and
maggots great just get it yes just get
it let's go
then do it
oh god oh she's still life sake a
wholesale I'm gonna lose in the rope
okay we got her neck this would work I
was gonna save her
i position my hand on psychos shoulder
and began filling around for the nut but
then oh god damn it no
her thin neck snapped easily god no no
psycho psycho snake was twisted
unnaturally her arms and her legs hung
limply and swayed back and forth with
the momentum on my fall she would
struggle no more you no no no I could
still feel the sensations of what that
last moment of my head I was responsible
for this I broke her neck
I killed psycho ah I clapped my hands on
either side of my head and curled up in
a fetal squat this was old prejudice
predestined to happen it was an
inescapable fate but somehow I should
have been able to change it fear despair
anger we're all swirling around inside
my head and I couldn't do a thing to
quell them I knew what I was I knew what
was going to happen I knew it but I
couldn't stop it what the hell is wrong
with me I just went through the same
emotions as before and we the exact same
mistakes and now psycho
dammit son-of-a-bitch
we got the Z wrong and huh
well-well-well
wrong and one where does it take us back
though where do we go
[Music]
really so if I didn't save I'd basically
have to redo every [ __ ] single thing
haha okay well good thing I save okay
every I think it's something else
ribs I mean no I remember now the bottom
rock is arrested there must be some
other way if you're farted damn it ii
was stretching my put it on your
shoulders all I could see is how much
your body the ring road was proof
positive that she wanted to live I'm
going to save you I swear it was going
to be alright
I could see the future fate was on my
side for a change
grab her booty body I knew I had to lift
suck a spot into the air loosing the
pull on the rope so she could breathe
unfortunately oh god damn it
psycho inadvertently kicked him me
square in the jaw damn it the force a
blow cost me two stubble and fall
backwards psycho ah she's really
suffering I have to hurry now damn it
god damn damn damn
damnit alright well let's do this right
this [ __ ] time and we need to save
her bros we can do it yeah damn it Edgar
keeps farting though it's [ __ ] gross
he bros are lucky not to feel this
[ __ ] pain that I'm going through
alright come on
something else this resist the
temptations of what this game puts in
front of you and just hit something else
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
alright think of something else huh
alright well [ __ ] it no wait I remember
this tube if I try to lift her I'm just
going to end up pulling down on her
harder and breaking her neck ah ah
psycho what do I do there has to be
something else see this is what I would
do let's just do it okay boys strap on
your shoulders that was it I needed to
lift her higher up
I had in my pokémon center okay
it's created enough I took a step
forward and actually pushed her into it
holding her in this place head wouldn't
drop okay does that work
does that work splutter
cargo [ __ ] ii stay with me breathe
wheeze spluttering breathe three wheeze
wheeze pants I'm gonna get you out of
this rope now okay just hold still all
the hair of my body was standing on the
end I actually did it I averted fate I
prevented psycho step high finebros
sorry I could feel it all through my
being I had just stepped into a new
world a new destiny it was an odd
sensation my - every my memories of that
horrible future had ground to a halt I
had no idea what would happen from now
on it seems the only memories I retained
from that other timeline was the ones
relating to my dearest friends demise
sago had stop squirming and simply it's
slumped over a sauce it from the whole
ordeal I reached my hand up to her neck
gently and carefully and after a lot of
fumbling Isis X I successfully untied
the knot on the Rope my sweet sweet
sweet pant peeling little up the slack
news off of psychos net neck made a sort
of crackling sound from each young I was
in a non how much force that rope had
exerted it was painful just thinking
about it up and through this morning she
was all smiles and laughter she was
always thinking about me and all was so
kind of not going why did something so
horrible have to happen to her but there
was nothing to be afraid of anymore
psycho now how now bypass the sad faith
that had previously awaited us as long
as the two of us were together would
make it through this I looked down at
psycho still breathing and sobbed
I led psycho at the stall and gently
laid her down the bathroom floor she was
too weak to go any further just yet
psycho you idiot why would you try and
hang yourself while I was so so was so
worried about you Donna you have no idea
I led my head on her body she was so
warm I was going to let her go again I
wasn't going to let her it let anyone
take it away from me it's okay it's okay
now
I'm sorry psycho I won't ever leave you
alone again Wow
do you understand can you see me it's me
Naomi
what is it was psycho yeah what's wrong
it's it's me it's me yeah Oh Barbara
she's talking octopus language don't
worry about it
psycho wasn't acting like yourself she
was regarding me as if she'd just seen a
ghost
her face was plainly painted with abject
fear from the very depths of her soul
she stumbled to her feet clumsily then
hey singly darted out the room nay psych
psycho what what I don't understand why
was she confused either way I had to
catch her yeah good know what to [ __ ] my
god wait tell me what's wrong it's me
now me
I kept pace with psychos frantic
unsteadily sprinting as she turned the
corner and a headed down the staircase
and then oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god no
is bad Oh
every time
no why why Seiko I saved you I just
saved you yeah
I smell is rotten yeah I'll pour you for
you did you really think you could save
her
once someone fate passes through these
halls it locks its place forever don't
you see if your destiny is to die here
then that's what's going to happen no
matter what and the way you die will
just keep getting worse and words every
time good girl good girl
don't worry I'll gladly extract all your
painful memories for now this isn't your
first time here after all you have all
the time in the world to savor all the
new and speakable ways your friend
[Music]
no sorry
such unbelievable cruelty this was
inhuman mell events the likes of which
I'd never imagined could exist oh god oh
god that's [ __ ] up because of my own
overzealous actions psychic wound up
meeting a fate even worse than death by
hanging it's my fault my fault my tears
began raining down on the sake of cheek
and on her forehead into her nose into
her mouth into her eyes but take his
eyes wouldn't close despite lacking the
ability to focus any more she just kept
staring right at me
Oh Seiko what are you looking at right
now what thoughts are going through your
mind why did you run from me earlier why
were you so afraid but no matter how
many times I asked these questions
psycho just wouldn't answer I told her
we'd always be friends no matter what
that would always be together answer me
please say something don't leave me
alone I could still feel the warmth from
sega's head in my arms but she was gone
now it was I was powerless all I could
do was scream there was nothing else to
do nothing would change
not that the screaming help all that
that did was echo back at me as if
mocking my back oh sorry I felt like I
was trapped in a cold damp shell so I
had no doubt in my mind that this was
hell why did we have to put through this
nightmare
god I can't take it anymore get me out
of here somebody please save me that was
[ __ ] wonderful
oh my god Oh God ah Jesus oh my god this
game me that's corpse party for you
jesus [ __ ] christ man oh my god oh my
god this game is so insane I forgot how
[ __ ] crazy it is well that was a
crazy ride I hope you bros appreciated
that this video was really long but I
also appreciate that you bros watched
the whole thing with me I think that's
super cool of you those thank you I had
a lot of fun hanging out with you bros
today that was really cool and what's
more exciting about it it's like we have
a lot of more chapters in front of us so
if you bros appreciated this thing
please show your support by liking and
favoriting and sharing this video
because that means I can do more of them
and we have a lot in front of us so
thank you for us for being a bro and
showing your support thank you for
watching as always we'll see you in the
next one stay awesome breath
[Music]